[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález la pandemia
de kobe 19 aún no termina y los
gobiernos de los países de la región de
américa latina y bueno también del
continente americano en general hacen
grandes apuestas para reactivar las
economías fuertemente golpeadas por la
crisis sanitaria el 2021 cerró con una
alta inflación con un aumento en los
precios derivados de diferentes factores
como por ejemplo factores climáticos
políticos sociales problemas en el
suministro mundial y pues por supuesto
la pandemia de kobe 19 en el 2022 hemos
visto que la inflación sigue sin techo
no sólo en américa latina sino también
en el mundo pero en la región se
acentuaron problemas de base como la
baja inversión la baja productividad la
informalidad y la falta de inversión
también en programas sociales veamos
algunas de las cifras de las grandes
economías de la región son cifras de
inflación interanual para el mes de
marzo el más reciente dato revela que
méxico alcanzó el 7,45 por ciento
-colombia 8,53 por ciento brasil 11 3 %
hay casos muy interesantes que también
vamos a analizar en el programa con
nuestros invitados y son los casos de
argentina y de venezuela con inflación
es sumamente altas y grandes problemas
económicos como pueden hacer frente a la
recuperación económica tras la pandemia
de kobe 19 ya lo vamos a ver en unos
minutos
pero la recuperación económica de
américa latina está ligada a otro factor
que tal vez no teníamos entre los
cálculos y es la guerra en ucrania una
guerra que amenaza con prolongarse y eso
traerá serias consecuencias para
nuestras economías y por ende pues para
la inflación se lo explicamos a
continuación veamos la guerra en ucrania
le sigue pasando factura a la economía
mundial y golpea con más fuerza los
precios de la canasta familiar en marzo
eeuu a registró la tasa de inflación
interanual más alta desde 1981 con un
8,5 por ciento una cifra impulsada por
los altos costos de la energía los
alimentos y la vivienda esta inflación
está carcomiendo el sueldo de los
empleados lo estamos viendo en este
momento si comparamos los salarios hace
un año hasta ahora
el estadounidense medio ha perdido 2.7
por ciento del poder adquisitivo el
índice de precios de mexico en marzo
subió hasta el 7,45 por ciento frente a
un año atrás una tasa que no se
registraba desde 2001 en colombia la
inflación de los últimos 12 meses hasta
marzo llegó al 8 53 por ciento y en
argentina se espera que en marzo la
inflación haya arrojado una tasa
interanual superior al 50 por ciento la
más alta de sudamérica después de
venezuela en ese país las organizaciones
sociales y políticas salieron a las
calles a protestar por el encarecimiento
de los precios forma pasaje
porque la inflación va comiendo y
pulverizando lo no fuera del salario de
las compañeras de los compañeros la
guerra ha sido apenas el agravante de
una elevada inflación que ya había
originado una pandemia del hub y 19 el
alza de precios del petróleo tras la
guerra la ralentización del crecimiento
en china y el atasco en las cadenas de
suministro son ahora la combinación de
factores que empeoran la situación a
nivel mundial
ya lo vemos esta preocupación ante el
aumento de la inflación es mundial no
solamente américa latina hace frente a
esta situación así lo indicó también la
directora gerente del fondo monetario
internacional kristalina georgieva
day concerning of course up el tema que
es muy preocupante por supuesto es el
impacto en la inflación it was not
before the best crisis era preocupante
antes de esta crisis ahora se puso peor
por sí misma debut y qué significa por
supuesto significa que habría un impacto
en los ingresos reales de las personas y
eso puede tener implicaciones para la
demanda pero también significa que se
pedirá a los bancos centrales que
intensifiquen sus acciones
access
entonces cuáles son los esfuerzos de los
países de américa latina para sacar
adelante sus economías cómo soportar una
pandemia que aún continúa y también las
consecuencias de la guerra en ucrania
que tanto sacrificios en planes sociales
inversiones y desarrollo tendrá que
hacer la región para sobrellevar esta
situación como enfrentamos la
recuperación económica y la inflación
sin techo es nuestro tema en el debate
de france 24 para analizar este tema
hemos invitado a alejandro chat fue en
ls columnista de la revista forbes y
también director gerente de
international action institute está en
la ciudad de washington en la capital de
eeuu y desde la ciudad de fort
lauderdale en el estado de florida en el
sur de eeuu se conecta esta conversación
claudio loser ls presidente de la
consultora centennial américa latina y
ex director para el hemisferio
occidental del fondo monetario
internacional fm y también ustedes
pueden participar dejando todas sus
preguntas y comentarios en las redes
sociales estamos en facebook en
instagram y en twitter no se encuentran
como arroba france24 jon bajo s santi
logo que es mi cuenta personal nuestra
etiqueta es numeral del debate efe 24
esperamos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas debe la bienvenida entonces al
debate a alejandro en la ciudad de
washington que fue la primera persona
que presente alejandro un gusto
saludarlo gracias por estar con nosotros
en el programa y pregunta de punto de
partida para este debate para este
análisis qué tan preparada hasta la
región de américa latina entonces para
hacer frente a estos múltiples retos
económicos que se le están presentando a
lo largo de este camino
está muy mal
preparada mis dos últimos artículos en
foros sobre latinoamérica era antes de
la pandemia de latinoamérica si no
estaba creciendo y a fines del año
pasado las estadísticas en casi todos
los países iban muy mal el secreto del
crecimiento económico a largo plazo los
economistas lo sabemos necesitamos un
marco de estado de derecho con propiedad
privada economías relativamente libres y
un marco de moneda sana para que los
inversores tengan cierto grado de
predictibilidad en su trabajo y eso está
faltando en la mayoría de los países de
latinoamérica así que es una de las
regiones peor preparadas estaría bien
preparada para afrontar la crisis
energética alimentaria pero
lamentablemente como la energía y el
petróleo están maniatados por el estado
y hay muchas reglas y regulaciones como
el país latinoamérica argentina podría
hoy ser un gran boom económico por los
alimentos que producen lo que va a
sufrir el mundo con la baja de la
producción en ucrania pero en vez de
liberar la economía cada vez ponen más
impuestos en ese país así que es muy
problemático para latinoamérica la
actual coyuntura internacional pero peor
es lo que los latinoamericanos y los
gobiernos están haciéndole a sus propios
ciudadanos el análisis de alejandra
ochoa fuentes de la ciudad de washington
vamos a ver qué piensa claudio loser
para este punto de partida del debate el
análisis él está como lo decía en la
ciudad de fort lauderdale hay la
bienvenida al programa claudio su
opinión que están preparadas está la
región cómo está el panorama o sea estoy
en este momento en washington estaba
cuando hicimos el acuerdo estaba en
forma de ley así que estoy acompañando
acá a mí a mi colega y bueno los dos
entonces desde la capital de eeuu
adelante de claudio
bien yo estoy de acuerdo en el drama de
américa latina' por supuesto como
persona originaria de argentina tengo un
sello muy fuerte para criticar a mi país
de origen y estoy totalmente de acuerdo
que es una situación terriblemente
difícil pero hay mirando las
estadísticas hay que reconocer que
américa latina en los últimos años ni
siquiera estoy hablando del periodo
digamos de pandemia y posterior ha
tenido un crecimiento bastante bastante
mediocre tuvo un crecimiento muy bueno
cuando los precios de los productos
estaban bien hoy en día uno puede decir
que para ciertos países pongamos brasil
y otros países productores de materias
primas puede haber una mejora relativa
es limitada evidentemente el shock de
los precios de los alimentos y de la
energía va a tener un impacto un impacto
negativo realmente en nuestra región
tiene muchos elementos
complejos que son difíciles de tratar
sin embargo tengo que decir que a pesar
de esta situación para la mayoría de los
de los países de la región aunque tengan
inflación es que no habían visto en
mucho tiempo no tienen inflación es
totalmente fuera de control no hablemos
de venezuela no hablemos de argentina
que son países que están cada uno a su
manera en una situación difícil pero las
otras están compitiendo
en términos de inflación con eeuu
así que yo diría es un problema pero
tengo confianza en la capacidad de los
bancos centrales de controlar esta
situación aunque
va a ser
difícil porque es un tratamiento como
dirá el dentista como largo
claudio alejandro cuáles países de la
región están capoteando sobrellevando la
situación de la mejor manera posible que
puedan tener de pronto una crisis de
inflación un poco más corta comparado
con otros países dejamos de lado el caso
de argentina y venezuela que lo vamos a
mirar en detalle aparte quiero hablar de
los países que podrían empezar a
presentar una recuperación un poco más
rápido o anticipada que otros comienzos
con claudio para hacer la ronda a la
inversa
si yo lo creo realmente que en méxico no
estoy hablando de las políticas
económicas en general de méxico que
tienen sus propios problemas
pero realmente
méxico puede capotear lo mejor dado que
está vinculado cercanamente a los eeuu y
con las dificultades de china yo creo
que méxico tiene posibilidades de
crecimiento como digo sujeto a las
políticas claras macroeconómicas y de
otro tipo del gobierno federal yo creo
que
otros países que lo pueden manejar bien
son
colombia de alguna manera en brasil
hasta cierto punto debido a la bonanza
de los precios flag y por otro lado no
estoy seguro pero por su situación
política muy muy delicada el chile que
normalmente sería uno de los países que
yo pondría adelante
no estoy seguro dado que no hay
suficiente certidumbre respecto de las
políticas a seguir por el nuevo
presidente en fake y si puede reaccionar
bien es uruguay país chico y otro país
pequeño que puede ser bien
y eso que colombia y brasil están en
carrera electoral y eso también afecta
mucho el panorama económico por la
incertidumbre que hay sobre todo en un
país como colombia alejandro además de
su perspectiva de los países que puedan
sobrellevar mejor esta situación
le alargó un poco la pregunta y le
extiendo hacia la inflación que estamos
viviendo como un fenómeno global parece
un fenómeno transversal para todos los
países a nivel mundial todos están
haciendo frente a estas secuelas
digámoslo así como consecuencia de la
pandemia kobe 19 hay forma de hacer
movimientos a nivel global para manejar
la situación en conjunto o toca país por
país región por región no se podría
hacer alguna algún movimiento a escala
mundial
toco este segundo punto para comenzar no
de ninguna manera es es algo que afecta
a los países por igual y que los países
lo van a sufrir por igual las
principales 20 economías del mundo vemos
tasas de inflación muy diferentes ya
hablamos del caso triste de argentina o
serbia turquía en otras regiones del
mundo pero países como suizo solamente
están teniendo un 2,42 5% de inflación y
no tienen y no tienen petróleo eeuu hoy
está en el peor tercio de esos 20 países
con arriba del 8% de inflación aquí el
aparato político y de medios quiere
culparles tu a putin pero en enero
cuando yo escribí el arte con un force
sobre la inflación la inflación ya venía
de arriba del 7% en el primer mes de
enero del 2021 con el presidente trap y
la inflación era 1.5 por la inercia de
la emisión monetaria que hicieron los
tres presidentes anteriores yo estaba
esperando a que la inflación creciera en
eeuu hacia el 34 por ciento pero nunca
estos niveles
altos que son resultados de que los
operadores económicos están
pronosticando y estaban viendo una
política de gobierno norteamericano que
en vez de promover la mayor producción
estaba proponiendo mayor y mayores
restricciones así que exigen se si la
culpa la tuviese putin la mayoría de los
países de los primeros 20 del mundo
tendríamos una tasa de inflación
parecida pero esto no es no es el caso
en el caso de la otra pregunta que tú
hiciste concuerdo mucho con el buen
economista
claudio loser tengo más dudas sobre
méxico y sobre países que enfrentan un
posible cataclismo o problema electoral
dado a la importancia que yo le doy al
estado de derecho uruguay solamente es
1% del producto bruto de latinoamérica y
si le veremos yo creo que ahora el
principal problema de presidente del
boliche es la constitución que es
horrenda pero el estado de derecho en
chile el el mal grado de libertad
económica en chile y su economía más
relativamente abierta o más abierta que
el resto del mundo se oponía también en
buena posición pero
no sabemos ahora hay también
incertidumbre en ese país ecuador es
otro país que todavía tiene tiene años
en el gobierno por delante de guillermo
lasso así que ellos también yo creo con
mi ex fórmula de moneda sana propiedad
privada y economía libre que para mí eso
es lo que tienen que aplicar los países
latinoamericanos y cuando lo aplicaron
todos los países latinoamericanos
crecieron
alejandros te mencioné el caso de eeuu
da varios detalles de las cifras de lo
que se esperaba que fuera a ser la
inflación en eeuu claramente las cifras
que vemos son superiores siendo estados
unidos la economía más importante del
continente americano esto como repercute
en las economías latinoamericanas en
países que son dolarizados en países que
dependen económicamente de eeuu en
cierta medida caso a méxico acaso
colombia países dolarizados como el
salvador ecuador panamá cuál es el
análisis que se puede hacer
bueno todo dependerá también de la
política cambiaria de muchos de estos
países y la tasa de intercambio y el
intercambio económico que tienen los
países con eeuu hoy en día el país que
tiene más relación económica de
latinoamérica con estados unidos en
méxico duele méxico y brasil son dos
tercios de latinoamericanos para poner
en perspectiva
tus a tus oyentes así que cuanto más
baratos sean los productos norteamérica
latinoamérica nos para los
norteamericanos si más o menos si no se
va de vuelta a una ola proteccionista
quizás algunos países latinoamericanos
pueden ver y verse beneficiados en
incrementar sus exportaciones a eeuu
pero todo depende de la política
monetaria cambiaria que apliquen y que
tengan los países de latinoamérica
hoy en día
claudio lamentablemente tengo que
llevarlos a hablar del caso argentina de
venezuela obviamente son son ejemplos
que dan para mucho análisis aquí en
nuestra región argentina venía
arrastrando muchísimos problemas
económicos la situación parece no
mejorar tan rápido como esperaban las
autoridades después de la pandemia ahora
se suma el tema de ucrania que tampoco
pues les ayuda a estabilizar precios y
vemos que la inflación está en unas
cifras muy altas el análisis que usted
puede hacer de argentina y del caso
venezolano que la buena noticia es que
se ha alejado un poco de la
hiperinflación
y yo tengo un problema con mi colega
alejandro aquí porque estoy totalmente
de acuerdo en su presentación
así que
en términos de los elementos cruciales
la argentina habla mucho de su de su
problema con la pandemia de su problema
con ucrania y todas esas cosas pero el
problema de argentina es un problema se
arrastra y hace años no es a mi juicio
él no es sólo de macri sino
fundamentalmente de los gobiernos
populistas anteriores
que no tuvieron no tienen ningún respeto
en términos de lo que yo considero un
elemento crucial que es la digamos la
estabilidad fiscal
en la argentina tiene el problema que
considera que no hay tal cosa como una
restricción presupuestaria alguna manera
ahora están tratando de controlarlo no
creo que en este momento la argentina
llegue a hiperinflación pero el programa
con el fondo
trabajado por mucho tiempo en el fondo
monetario internacional y yo veo que
este programa es el mínimo necesario
para poder sobrellevar
los próximos dos años con con suerte
la actividad económica de la argentina
el crecimiento económico de la argentina
aparte de venezuela ha sido el peor de
la región en los últimos años con caídas
fuertes en el en el ingreso per cápita y
eso es un problema y hay detrás de eso
un conflicto político es muy muy serio
el banco central en este momento está
tratando de hacer algunas cosas para
arreglarlo pero es muy pero esto va a
ser muy cuesta arriba con la sedición el
caso de venezuela
es un drama en última instancia es una
economía que sea la inflación casi no
tiene importancia es una economía de
hecho dolarizada pero con un ingreso que
es el es un ingreso bajísimo ha caído
realmente a menos de la mitad del
ingreso per cápita en los últimos años
eso sea es una verdadera tragedia y por
supuesto el hecho es que con el petróleo
se ha podido mantener no quiero hacer de
esto una discusión política
espero que el gobierno se ha podido
mantener
pagando a sus asociados cercanos con el
petróleo que se exporta en una actividad
cada vez menor y eso por sus extras es
que se tenga mucho poder pero yo diría
que la situación de venezuela es una
tragedia terrible y la de argentina una
tragedia cuando estábamos llegando a la
meta del programa me quedan muchos temas
todavía por conversar alejandro quiero
preguntarle por
los aspectos que usted mencionaba en su
intervención al inicio del programa
usted hablaba de una posible crisis
alimentaria a nivel internacional por
como derivado de lo que se está viviendo
en ucrania esta falta de suministros de
trigo ucrania es uno de los grandes
productores de trigo a nivel
internacional ya vemos los precios a
dónde han llegado y esto cómo afecta
américa latina' estamos al inicio a la
vuelta de la esquina de una crisis
alimentaria a nivel internacional
bueno nuevamente
a nivel internacional las
generalizaciones a veces sirven para
ciertos análisis pero son muy simplistas
no va esto va a afectar en forma
distinta a varios países a algunos
países del medio oriente que importan
mucho de su trigo que pueden tener un
problema mayúsculo no creo que esta
crisis alimentaria se dé de la misma
manera en países
de latinoamérica o países de los que que
tienen una gran producción interna de
alimentos para tus oyentes por más que
el doctor láser y yo que venimos de
distintos mundos a cada año creo que los
dos tratamos de mirar seriamente la
economía y por eso cuando tenemos que
mirar la realidad estamos de acuerdo así
hablamos de una otra tema quizás
estaríamos muy en desacuerdo pero en
este tema realmente si emitir moneda
sería la solución a los problemas
económicos argentinos sería el país más
rico del mundo y concuerdo con lo que
dijo también venezuela es eso aparte es
una especie de estado y mafia narco
magia que se escapa a los análisis de
todo parámetro y tiene un gran producto
de enorme demanda en el mundo que es el
petróleo lamentablemente han disminuido
su productividad en la producción del
petróleo la tierra argentina es siempre
un enigma un país que escapa a las
estadísticas porque tiene un potencial
enorme muchas de sus zonas pero tiene
ese cáncer que es la falta de estado
derecho y falta de convencimiento en la
élite política de es que es necesario
ajustarse los panteones y tener esa
disciplina fiscal que claudio los que la
violó se te explico
alejandro en cuanto a la situación que
está viviendo europa en este momento en
donde muchos países del bloque de la
unión europea están determinados a
cortar el suministro de gas y de carbón
procedente de rusia también están
buscando nuevas fuentes para abastecerse
de petróleo de otros países del cáucaso
y del medio oriente américa latina tiene
alguna oportunidad de allí también como
usted menciona en la parte alimenticia
que tal vez no afecte mucho a la región
de américa latina porque somos
productores y no afectará tanto como
países del medio oriente que
oportunidades entonces tenemos en esos
escenarios
bueno hay menos oportunidad de exportar
energía a europa en la que tiene eeuu el
norte de áfrica y otras regiones más
cercanas
a europa pero estamos desperdiciando
lamentablemente por problemas
ideológicos no como venimos acarreando
en muchos sectores populares una especie
de animosidad contra eeuu es un momento
que latinoamérica podría muchos países
latinoamericanos podrían aprovechar para
a entrar más fuerte y no solo en la
economía de eeuu y en la economía
europea lamentablemente hoy está en su
última década el gran socio comercial de
latinoamérica es china dominada por el
partido comunista y que se mueve con
parámetros muy distintos que la economía
del primer mundo china ha estado
ayudando a rusia en su proceso de
invasión a ucrania es un país que si se
debilita rusia si se debilita a eeuu y
europa va a salir ganando por los
enormes intereses que tiene en su
corredor grande que da desde china a
europa que pasa en uno de los lugares
más principales por ucrania que sus
raíces que donde a china tiene muchas
inversiones también
parques y que son los países de asia
central que tienen conexión directa con
las fronteras chinas claudio regresó con
usted también en la ciudad de washington
allí en la capital de eeuu para
preguntarle por este tema
las oportunidades que pueda tener
américa latina con estas dos coyunturas
la coyuntura que se está viviendo en
europa y lo que se puede presentar en
materia alimentaria en unas semanas en
unos meses no podríamos decirlo cuando
pero podría suceder dada la situación
que estamos viviendo el panorama que
tenemos
si me permite usar una terminología en
nota no técnica a la oportunidad la
pintan calva tiene que aprovecharse
rápidamente yo diría lo siguiente en la
parte del petróleo
está la situación como como les
explicaba
alejandro
por supuesto en la parte alimenticia
está la siguiente situación
el tema agrícola
es estacional en este momento en el
hemisferio sur que es el sur de brasil
paraguay
argentina uruguay chile
la cosecha de alguna manera está
terminando no se puede vender más pero
no se puede producir más en este momento
han habido problemas también
climáticos entonces la situación allí es
que podría aprovecharse si dentro
incluso del esquema de protección social
lo pongo entre comillas no no voy a
entrar a la parte ideológica de eso se
cortarán todo tipo de
restricciones que existen a las
exportaciones por ejemplo en argentina
de restricciones de exportaciones que en
última instancia bajan los precios y
bajan los incentivos
y la argentina y estos otros países
podrían todos aprovechar y poder entrar
en el mercado rápidamente para compensar
lo que es la parte agrícola una cosa
interesante aunque en ucrania y rusia
son importantes productores y solo
importantes exportadores determina la
producción mundial los números que yo he
visto y esto el sujeto corrección es que
rusia y ucrania no tienen más que el 5%
de la producción total de trigo en el
mundo o sea desde ese punto de vista yo
no diría podría compensarse pero por
supuesto los mercados no sancionan en
forma tan tan tan rápida y eficiente
pero tendría que ver rusia y rapidez
astucia y rapidez por parte de los
gobiernos latinoamericanos eso me lleva
a claudio a la siguiente pregunta
también sin ánimo de entrar en polémica
en términos ideológicos pero que tanto
sacrificio tendrán que hacer los
gobiernos los presupuestos en términos
de ayudas sociales de programas sociales
que venían en marcha que se pusieron a
trabajar para poder enfrentar los dramas
sociales por la pandemia de kobe 19 para
poder impulsar las economías de los
países es fácil para américa latina'
hacer un balance frente a esos dos
aspectos o claramente hay que sacrificar
el aspecto social
evidentemente américa latina' hizo un
esfuerzo importante yo creo que digamos
el apoyo en los sectores de menos
ingresos es un tema no sólo social sino
un tema económico
pero yo diría que
bueno eso fue en el año
2020 y en principios del 2021 seguir en
este momento es de alguna manera como
pasó en eeuu que dieron una digamos un
empujón muy fuerte al gasto social
hace un año cuando no hacía falta o sea
la economía de latinoamérica no está
creciendo como alguna otra pero está
creciendo sin necesidad de o sea yo creo
que habría que
mejorar la calidad del gasto ha habido
en la historia latinoamericana
paquetes de ayuda a los más necesitados
pero cuando uno mira a los subsidios que
se dan en forma indiscriminada a la
población en la argentina en un caso
particular pero en todos los en muchos
de los países latinoamericanos también
uno dice no puede ser que no sea proteja
por acciones políticas a todos los
sectores porque no se puede proteger en
todos los sectores cuando la situación
es difícil
-alejandro regreso con ustedes allí en
la capital de eeuu hablamos de la
oportunidad que tiene la región de
américa latina como productor de
alimentos pero por ejemplo
puede ser una buena ecuación puede ser
estratégico para la región teniendo en
cuenta que el 20 por ciento de los
fertilizantes que importa la región de
américa latina proceden de rusia son
fabricados en rusia y en este momento
precisamente algunos países ya están
presentando escasez de fertilizantes
esto no va a generar más problemas en la
producción
en los cultivos que hay en américa
latina'
y subirán y subirán los precios porque
vuelta los costos el aumento de los
costos no es la que produce inflación
porque si no hay si no se convalida con
emisión monetaria sin gasto más plata en
gasolina o nafta tengo menos plata para
gastar en otros bienes y los precios en
general nos suben pero acá a no
engañarse bueno yo no participo de lo
que se llama la economía que inician a
que pienso que la destrucción y las
guerras son buenas porque generan gasto
público tampoco pienso que el gasto
social es siempre social lo que le está
pagando muchas veces el apoyo es
indiscriminado en la mayoría de los
países en algunos se manejó mejor estas
ayudas condicionales a los sectores más
marginados pero la mayoría de los pastes
de países se repartieron estos fondos
como como botín político la mejor
política social es un trabajo productivo
es como se consigue un trabajo
productivo y hablamos de cuál es la
solución en la cruzaron no sólo los
países asiáticos que son de otra cultura
pero la cuyo irlanda que usaron todos
los países que estando a veces en crisis
trataron de reformar sus economías habló
también el placer de claudio sobre el
tema de los bancos centrales yo no soy
tan optimista con los bancos centrales
quizás como es él pero sí desde desde
1980 en adelante se aprendió mucho en el
tema monetario acuérdense
presidente cárter quien es negro a paul
volcker para parar la inflación con
tasas de interés más altas que la
inflación y también fue durante cárter
que trajo alfred khan que empezó a
regular la economía
lamentablemente no veo esa voluntad y
coraje político hoy en hoy en eeuu y en
otros países de latinoamérica clara
tienen que hacer un ajuste pero creo que
tienen miedo por mitos de teoría
económica a lo que puede suceder de
vuelta de la situación no es fácil pero
todo empieza con tener una economía sana
productiva competitiva que que ayude a
crear trabajos sanos y no solamente
ayuda social alejandro claro que me
quedan pocos segundos para finalizar el
programa la conclusión qué va a suceder
con la región de américa latina en
materia económica comienza
claudio 30 segundos por favor si la
situación económica es difícil para
empezar la crisis complica las cosas
pero es excusa para no hacer política
correcta yo creo que de todas maneras
tiene que aplicarse
políticas serias y ciertamente en la
parte macroeconómica como condición de
clase seria no hay milagros de otra
manera sale sangre soy su conclusión
concuerdo nuevamente con la 'q' con
claudio y pienso que el único país que
quizás no puede dar una sorpresa
quizás puede ser méxico pero por razones
muy difíciles raras de política y de
vecindad con estados unidos- más que por
otra cosa -alejandro claudio les
agradezco por este análisis para la
audiencia de france 24 ustedes pueden
seguir dejando sus preguntas y
comentarios en las redes sociales y
viendo la programación de france 24
sigas con nosotros
[Música]